Welcome, uh, to detection engineering
at scale building high fidelity security
operations.
Uh, I'm Andrew Krug, and, uh, I have
the privilege of leading the security advocacy
and research team at DataDog. We're
the team that, uh, writes Dataog security labs
and the, uh, state of, uh,
insert thing here, uh, research studies
if you're familiar with those,
and I'm joined today by a fantastic
co-presenter from one of our customers.
Hi everybody, uh, my name is Nathan. Uh,
I am a senior security engineer at Riot Games.
Um, I have 6 years of experience in
security. Uh, been at Riot for about 4
years, and then before that, you know,
had 22 other years in 2 other companies.
Um, before that I was actually a software dev,
uh, Riot,
you know, I'm on the security operations team where we
basically do. All the blue team stuff
that you can think of, you know, threat hunting, section
engineering,
uh, threat intel, forensics, incident response,
and I can keep going, yada yada yada,
um, personally, you know, I love building tools
which make our life easier. It's probably the
software dev and me a little bit.
And outside of work, I have 3 cats
and a fun fact is I used to coach professional
Overwatch.
Thank you, Andrew.
Great, so, uh, before we get into this, just
super curious, how many folks
do we have that are in security roles
in the room today? Like your primary job
is security.
And how many Dataog customers do we
have in the room today? You're already using DataDog.
All right, cool,
thank you so much.
So we're, we're here today to talk about
detection engineering and
put simply, detection engineering
is the act of writing detections
to find threats
and misconfigurations.
Today we're gonna talk to you about detection
engineering as it relates to detection
as code, which is the act of applying
SDLC principles to authoring
detections.
Getting this right
a very high percentage of the time if
you practice this
can be incredibly challenging, so
we're gonna share a little bit of advice on
some best practices here and what's worked
really well for Riot.
But first let's just kind of examine a little bit
of the problem space that we're working in here
and we're trying to solve with this detection as
code approach and that's
that really we're all dealing with tons and
tons of logs and the slide says logs as
infinite as stars in the night sky
because that is generally
representative of the number of systems that you could
potentially be ingesting logs from
in your environment today, so.
Obviously like you were all building
on AWS,
which means that you have at least
4 logs probably uh
in your environment and then tons and
tons beyond that but everybody has like kind of these
staple logs that we're all dealing with
like AWS cloud trail
workload security logs from your endpoints,
network contacts coming from things like BPC
flow logs,
and now with AI platforms,
tons and tons of logs coming from things like.
Uh, agentic workflows and platforms
like Bedrock.
So our goal at the end of the day, which
sometimes we have to remind ourselves of
when we're looking at all this data, is that
we just want to detect when bad stuff happens.
And that should be in a way
that is contextual and
actionable.
So if you're not familiar with kind of the detection
development life cycle, uh, this is, um,
the go to detection development life
cycle by hater dost,
um, it kind of details a few of
the phases that that folks go through whether
they're using a software development life
cycle approach or just manually building
detections at all.
You kind of go through the requirements gathering phase like
what is the thing that I want to detect and
basically for that
when do I set it at a high enough severity that
I wanna do something like wake somebody
up. Then we design that detection,
we develop it,
and where this kind of falls apart most of the
time is in testing and
development. So how do we reliably know
for an event that should never take place
in our business that that alert is going
to fire when we need it most
and how do we do that on an ongoing basis?
And then as the application stack evolves
as the threat space evolves,
at what point do we decide
to actually retire that detection because
it's no longer relevant. So
that's where
SDLC can be really, really helpful
and so we're gonna, we're gonna highlight a little bit of that
when we get into
the hands on portion of the session.
If you are doing manual detection
engineering and just curious how many people are just like
building alerts in the in the SIM that
you're in today if you wanna
raise hands, yeah, quite a, quite a few
folks, uh, building alerts manually. So
if you, if you're doing that,
you are familiar with some of the challenges that
come from anything that is effectively click
ops. We have a lack of version control and audit
history. We have siloed development
in users that have access, so
sometimes we don't even have shared visibility across
the entire organization.
We have inconsistent quality for those
and output and then they become increasingly
difficult to manage at scale, so the
more detections you have, the
broader this problem kind of becomes
so long as you're doing it manually.
So in order to address some of those
challenges,
security engineers began to apply
SDLC principles.
This is no surprise because we're really just taking the
things that we've learned from like DevOps,
Devsecops factory patterns, and we're
applying them to writing detections
and managing the life cycle of those.
So for all of these things we're going
to introduce things like version control
and peer review.
Obviously in order to do that, the SIM
that you're using behind the scenes has to have some
kind of mature API in order
for you to interact with that.
We're gonna talk about testing and validation
and like for some
complex incidents, the validation of
specific type of types of alerts might involve
very long windows of time, so we're gonna give
some advice on.
Just like how do you backtest
uh those those rules against historic
data, then we put those in CICD
we make sure that they're syntactically valid
and then uh another big concept here
that we're gonna discuss is reusability and modularity
because you might be detecting the same things
in a number of systems
just with
one minor change so the more that you can
modularize that,
uh, obviously the, uh, the fewer
potential errors you're going to have in that code.
So the goal of a detection engineer
is really to write a perfectly
accurate detection, and we'll get into like
what I mean when I say perfectly accurate here in
just a second.
But in practice
this is almost unachievable
100% of the time, so that's
something that we have to accept
going into it that we need to adopt
almost a good enough for now mindset.
So some terminology here, uh, that you should be familiar
with if you're in this space is that we have this
notion of perfect recall,
uh, in detection engineering, and that means
that the system identifies 100%
of actual malicious events with
zero false negatives, and that sounds
pretty cool in, in, uh, in
theory, but in practice this is
one of the most challenging things to do
in detection engineering.
Then we have perfect precision,
so that means that
we can detect a bunch of things, we group them
into a basket, and then we throw out
the false positives to increase the
fidelity
of that detection so it only fires
when a genuine malicious event has
occurred and if you're following the AI space,
this is where LLMs are really,
really helpful for folks.
And the reality is that most people are writing rules
that we are somewhere in this middle ground,
um, because we want to detect
a an amount of time that's meaningful
with some confidence and we're actually most of
the time
pretty OK with a low rate of false
positives,
but if we have too many false positives, that's
where we get into the noise problem
and people start to lose confidence
in the detection system.
So the reality is we're always making trade-offs
and I, I, I can't think of a better
analogy than this one here where, what
you could think of maximizing recall
as a smoke detector analogy where you want
it to go off, you're kind of OK with some false
positives because the consequences of it not
going off
are maximum risk
and then in the case when you're writing an alert that wants more
precision, you can think of something like a spam
filter where we actually
wanna avoid false positives almost
all of the time
because somebody might miss a message.
So we need to find the middle
ground, which means understanding
for the thing that we're trying to detect
what is our tolerance for false positives.
How do we, how can we use historical
data to gauge how that rule will
will perform and then further tune it
to reduce the false positive rate?
We need to continuously monitor the rule performance
for false positives and see how that's
trending in real life once we
move it into the production SI environment.
And then we need to determine the impact of tuning
that rule
over time because like maybe the log sources
change, maybe the nature of our
application changes, maybe there's another security control
that does something like reduces the volume
of events coming into that thing.
So now I'm gonna hand it over to
uh Nathan from Riot to talk a little
bit about how they have leveraged
the Data Dog cloudsim to build a
detection as code platform.
Thank you, Andrew.
OK,
so.
We're today we're gonna talk about 3 different challenges.
Um,
first one we're gonna talk about is sort of relates to what Andrew
was talking about earlier,
uh, about like logs as the infinite
sky, right?
Um,
these are challenges that we've sort of dealt with and sort of
solutions that we've come up with for them. So the first one, right,
is if we log too much, right, that's obviously
gonna cost a lot of money and it's gonna break the bank,
but if we log too little, then we
lose signal because we can't write detections
because we don't have the logs we need.
So, how do we find this perfect ground
of being able to log
everything we want
and also being able to sort of like filter what we don't
need, but maybe still keep it.
So, this is where
this sort of comes into play, SIM optimization.
Uh, we had this
problem. This is sort of the 6 points we have for sort
of what we want criteria for trying to solve this.
So the first one is we wanted to filter early
and save big. So we want to be able to filter before
stuff actually goes into our SIM.
We want to be able to adapt on the fly,
and we want to be able to normalize for clarity.
We want to stay resilient,
we want to scale with confidence, and we want to enforce
data hygiene.
So I'm gonna go into a few of these in a little bit more depth,
right? So filter early, save big.
Why does this matter? Well,
When people send us logs,
sometimes they mess up.
And what I mean by mess up, they send us
way too much.
And then what ends up happening is our SIM
explodes in the sense of like, we're ingesting a
lot of data,
we're indexing a lot of data and that costs a lot of money,
and that's not good.
So, we need a way to be able to filter data
before it actually gets into our SIM.
Um, adapt on the fly, scale with confidence,
right? This sort of goes in hand with what I just mentioned, right?
We need to be able to, if people do send us
a lot of data, we don't want our like infrastructure
to break, we wanna be able to scale,
OK? So we'll, in a minute, we'll look at
sort of a infrastructure diagram of
everything is sort of built on AWS native service
services.
Um, it was actually built by a coworker
on a team, uh, called Nathan Martini. Um,
I'm one of the engineers that helps maintain it.
Um, and the last thing I want to sort of talk about is enforced
data hygiene.
So, what I mean by this is that
sometimes we want to make sure that we're getting these log sources,
we put important tags, right? So we care
about maybe like environment. So we want maybe to know
if the log source is
prod, Dev, or something else,
or we maybe wanna know about a log source owner, so
that if something happens to that log source, we actually know
who we need to contact
to, you know, figure out what's going wrong.
So, let's sort of jump ahead. Let's look at this infrastructure
diagram.
Um, so what I wanna call out first is sort of
top left. You can see public, uh,
collector, private collector.
So this is where sort of the journey starts, right?
Uh, we have situations where we have third party,
uh, vendors, tools that
wanna send us logs.
We also have situations where we have internal teams that wanna
send us logs. You can probably think of, you know.
Our our networking team that want to send us pan
traffic and pan threat logs so
we need to be able to have collectors that work
for both public and private, um,
so teams would basically send it there. Uh, we have
specific ports for a different type of log
sources, um, it just helps keep things a little
bit organized and then behind that
is essentially an auto scaling group,
uh, that is running vector.
So if you're not familiar with Vector, Vector is an open
source log shipper with transformation
functions written in Rust,
Rust. Uh, this is actually by
Data Dog. Um, I really, really
like it.
Um, so after anyway, logs
get sent to Autoscale and Groupon Vector. It
then goes to Kafka, right, for back pressure.
And then from there, it goes to ECS container
service that's also running Vector. However, with
this one,
what's happening here is this is where we're actually gonna be doing a lot of
our filtering.
So this is where we might say, hey, like,
you are blasting us with data, and we need a
quick way to like, you know, stop that
thing from blasting us.
We're gonna be able to make a change here and be able to drop
data. Or here we might be able to add some tags.
Um, then from here,
stuff goes to DataDog,
then from Dataog goes to our store Ts,
then from there, goes to Jira, and then
eventually Slack, cause we all love Slack, you
know, Slack opps is a great thing.
Um, one more thing before I move on from
the slide I want to talk about is
sort of like what Andrew's talking about, right, with,
you know, CICD infrastructures code,
uh, PRs, uh, when
Nathan Martini designed this, one of the really cool
things he added was that a GitHub
repo that basically stores our vector
configuration files.
So. So whenever we want to make an update to
our vector configs, all we have to do is
literally
make a new branch, make a PR with, you
know, with the file,
put it to the branch of like the, uh, with
the environments staging prod, and push it.
And then we even have monitors and whatnot set up in Dataog
to actually see
if stuff actually got pushed successfully
and whatnot.
So, let's sort of
go a little bit more into vector, right? So we talked
a little bit about what it is.
Uh, let's sort of look at an example of what a vector configuration
looks like.
So, how I like to sort of describe vector,
if you're not familiar with it, is there's like 3
main things in it.
There is the source,
right, where you're sort of getting data from. There's
transforms,
and then there's a sync where you're gonna send data.
Pretty straightforward, I feel like.
Uh, so, this example we're looking at right over here, uh,
let's sort of pretend that vector is running on that
laptop right over there doing the presentation.
Uh, let's pretend it. You're running as a service
or Docker or whatever you would like to run it as,
uh, if we look at this example here, it's saying source
is Windows event logs and specifically
grabbing security logs.
Cool, so it's grabbing security logs. What is it doing with
it? Well, let's look at transforms.
So what it's doing now is is actually adding a field
called log source owner, which value
security team.
Cool, as I talked about before, tagging data.
Next, what it's doing is sync, which
in this case, it's sending it to Datao.
So it's like a very relatively simple example.
Um,
next, let's sort of like think about
how we'd want to do something with maybe S3 data.
So, let's look at an example with cloud trail logs,
right? Most people have cloud trail logs,
they send it to an S3 bucket, and they wanna do stuff with
it. So in this example, a little bit more
complicated for a source.
We have AWSS 3 as a type,
we have a bucket,
we have a region.
And then we have file prefix and then obviously,
you know, codec JSON and whatnot.
So we're grabbing our S3 data from the bucket.
We're then doing another transform. However, in
this situation, we're actually doing a delete on
an event version.
And this is honestly just an example to sort
of highlight that, you know, we can do transforms
like. I talked about earlier,
where if we want to delete fields, let's delete
it, right?
Certain log sources sometimes
come in with fields that are quite big,
not useful, and honestly, we just don't need
it. So why even ingest it, right?
If it's not gonna be useful in our detections, why would
we want to keep it?
And not even detections, incident response, or even threat hunting.
And lastly, like the, like the previous
slide,
sink going to data dog.
So hopefully from these two slides you sort of got an example
of what vector sort of looks like. Um,
I will be honest, our vector configurations a little
bit more complicated. We probably have a few more sources,
um, and
maybe one or two more sinks, but it should give
you a good idea.
So now, let's look at a summary of what
we sort of just covered.
So, in summary, right,
we built something that is built for speed.
We wanted to collect all our data, and
we wanted to be able to send
anywhere. So, an example in that infrastructure diagram
where we saw that ECS it's sending a data doc.
Realistically, we could take that and send it
anywhere. We saw in the end with the vector configuration,
the sync's there, so we could point that other places.
This allows us to be flexible, which is honestly
invaluable.
Next, we, we can filter out the edge, which we
talked about.
We wanna be able to enrich on the fly. We saw examples of
being able to add tags
to log sources or fields to log sources, as
well as delete stuff.
And then we wanna be able to stay in control,
which is our infrastructures code, our PR,
um, being able to PR stuff, and it's flexible by
design. So,
what's the next problem, right? So we've talked about
this whole thing of like, log ingestion,
right? Now, the question is, are we gonna actually,
all this data that's going to DataDog, are we actually
going to ingest it all
or index it all?
How did, how is that gonna work,
right? So, the answer is,
right, it's gonna depend.
And I'll give you an example of a blog source
like Pan traffic, right? That's a pretty noisy,
like log source.
Do I need that for detection engineering? Do
I need that for rat hunting? Do
I need it for incident response?
Well, probably may not need it for detection
engineering. So then, do I actually
need to index it?
But if an incident happens and I need to look at my pan traffic
logs, I might need to look at it later.
So how can I handle this?
And this is where sort of storage and rehydration
come into effect.
So, what is storage and rehydration, right?
Storage, you can even call it archiving if you want.
But in very simple terms,
right? Basically, what's happening here is we're grabbing
a log source,
and we're just gonna send it to SS 3 bucket.
And then from there, when we want the data,
we're gonna rehydrate it from an S3 bucket.
So now let's say we're looking at our pan traffic logs
and we're like, OK, cool, we got these.
Let's ingest them. Let's not index them
because it's expensive. When we have a threat
hunt that we want to do or we have an incident
so that we need to look into things, then we'll
go in and we'll actually
pull it back from that estuary bucket that we archived it to.
So, let's look at a deeper example of what this sort of looks
like in the GUI.
Uh, I honestly really like Tatter Dog's GUI. I think
it's, uh, done pretty well.
Uh, so, in the very top right, uh,
top right, we can set an archive name,
we can specify the filter based off a query
of what we actually wanna send.
What's nice about this part is that we can actually
be very fine tuned on what we want. We're not just sending
a log source, we can go and do a sub of that log
source. For this example right over here,
we're looking at pan firewall, but then
we're particularly choosing type Global Protect AKA
VPN logs, which realistically,
you'd probably index, but for compliance reasons,
you probably need to keep your VPN logs for,
you know, a long time.
Next, we look at our archive types. So you probably
set up an IM role for AWS.
You then look to, you know, set up an AWS account, S3
bucket, path, you know, choose your storage type.
Cool. So now we got a little
understanding of like how we're storing these logs,
let's sort of look at like a sample use case.
So, this is a rough use case. Um,
so, let's say we've got
questionable activity from ex-user. Let's pretend that
ex user is me. Let's say that I'm
malicious or I'm doing weird things.
Um, and we need to backtrack, you know,
who, what IP address I had,
uh, you know, for my VPN sessions cause
I'm working remote, and we need to figure out what I was doing,
and then like, you know,
was I allowed to do that,
right? And so in this case, let's say I needed to rehydrate
logs to be able to do this.
So let's look at what that would look like in rehydration.
So, on the right side again, we can see the rehydration
gooey. So in this situation, you can
see on the very top, what we're going to do is we're going to rehydrate
a time period.
So if I know that, you know, I was doing some weird
stuff, maybe 232 days ago,
right? I'm going to focus on that time period.
Next, we're gonna choose the archive name,
and then we're gonna choose the actual query,
right? So this is the part, these
two things I want to talk about a little bit more,
the time period and the query.
Normally, when you do rehydration, the biggest problem
is it takes a lot of time.
Uh, I've done rehydrations on other, other tools and
products, and it's taken me probably 5 to 10
hours. If we have an incident,
5 to 10 hours is a long time,
that's a problem, right?
So, what's nice about this with the time
frame and the query is I can now
shorten that, right? Why?
Because if I know the time period I want, that's gonna reduce
the amount of logs I want to rehydrate.
On top of that, if I know that I'm only looking at
me, I can do something like at
user.name and pitch iconi at ridegames.com
and only get my logs. So now, again, we're
going from getting a bunch of VPN logs,
right? I'm short, I'm shortening it by a time frame,
and then also the user.
So this generally will take maybe like 5 to 10
minutes. That's a lot more reasonable in an incident
scenario incident response scenario.
So, what's another option, right,
instead of rehydration?
Uh, Andrew, would you like to talk about archive search?
Yeah, thanks. Uh,
sometimes you don't want to rehydrate
all of the logs in an
investigation back into an index just
to be able to see
if the needle even exists
inside the haystack, and I think this is one of the most
challenging things
in managing a logs platform is as a business
you're constantly having to balance the trade-off
of cost.
What do I keep in the hot index? What do
I keep in an S3 bucket? What do I send
to something like flex logs or a colder
storage to optimize further
so. Dataog archive search
is a new feature which allows
you to run a search query
off of data that lives in a platform like
S3.
And that's really, really cool for threat hunting
or forensics or incident response because
all of a sudden now
we can do an investigation on that slightly
colder storage that is much less
expensive
and then we can see if it's worth it to pull those logs
back in or rehydrate the logs
to go a little bit deeper. So archive search
is a net new feature that's available. Uh,
the docs are linked there in the slide.
Thank you, Andrew.
So, let's talk about challenge number 2, right? So we
just talked about like blogging, we talked a lot
about ingestion and dealing with like indexing
and ingestion.
But the reason why we want to start with that is because
detections are written on logs. But now let's
sort of get into more of the core issue of why we're here, right?
Detection is code. And Andrew did a really good
job in the introduction,
uh, sort of talking about what detection is code is.
So, as the challenge says, right, detection
quality doesn't come from more rules, it comes from a better
process. So,
Before I go into this a little bit more,
um,
I wanna state that when Riot started using
DataDog, we didn't really do detection
as code.
We were building rules in the GUI,
and I'll be honest, I really, really
still like the GUI, and we'll see why and when
we built our processes, that we still sort of use
the GUOUI and we sort of like
found an interesting way to do detection as code still.
So, let's do a quick summary again of just what detection
of code is, um, the core principles
being version control,
automated testing, collaboration and review,
and automation CICD.
So, I wanna talk a little bit more about
the collaboration and review.
One of the biggest issues with just not doing detection
as code, in my opinion, is simply typos.
Typos, testings, people
just making mistakes because, you know, that happens.
I have definitely written detections that I
thought worked, but I mistyped something.
I put, I maybe sent detection to the wrong notification,
maybe it was going to dead. It should go to prod and
that type of mistake can honestly be pretty critical,
right? If I was running a detection, uh, that
I knew for some malicious traffic that could happen in the future
and all of a sudden that detection will not work anymore,
that's a problem.
So this is where that collaboration and review part really comes
into effect with the whole GitHub, with the whole
GitHub part, with the PRs, right,
and reviewing.
Next part is the automation testing or automated
testing. In a little bit, uh, in a
second, we're gonna see sort of a demo of, you know, our whole
process, and we'll talk a little bit about how,
what this automated thing looks like. We're gonna
see sort of, you know, some basic Python scripts
being run to basically doing some simple validations
to make sure these rules are up to our standards
in terms of things that it should have, such as
maybe like minor techniques and tactics,
environment tax, um, make sure the
rule name makes sense, and other small
things like that as well as the rule is actually valid
itself. So without further
ado, let's sort of get straight into it.
Um, we're going to talk about how we
create a rule.
So right now, we're in the Data Dog GUI.
We are going to go straight, and
we're going to go straight and look to create a rule.
So right now, we can see that all the rules that
are enabled are, there's nothing there. There's nothing.
So we went first, we're gonna enable one,
we're going to focus on a threshold rule. There's a bunch
of different types, but we're going to keep it simple.
We're gonna go and we're gonna focus on a role. We're gonna
look at cloud trail, right, where AWS reinvent,
gotta do cloud trail. We're gonna focus on
uh stop logging. So, cause that's
would be weird. People shouldn't be stopping logs.
And then we're gonna group by an account ID.
Next thing I want to talk about is that preview matching
logs. So this is a right
on the bottom, that's a very helpful thing that basically
will allow us to do some testing on
basically if things exist for that query.
And one of the reasons why I like the GUI.
The next thing is we're going to define our rule condition and say
like, you know, if, if anything hits
or greater than 0, then alert,
then we're gonna add a rule name.
And we're gonna add a description
The other thing I wanted to mention as well, is
at the very bottom,
right after this is done, we're going to start adding tags.
So this is part of that part where
it's good practice, right?
When you're security operations, you probably want to start
using minor tactics and techniques.
And that's good for tracking purposes to see where your general
uh your general coverage is.
So we're gonna be looking to add both of those.
We'll also be looking to add
um my uh environment tag as well.
It'll take 1 2nd. My typing is
unfortunately a little slow.
But while it's happening, the other thing on the bottom, you can
see is create suppression.
And I'm not going to go into this today, but we've actually also
CICD our suppressions as well.
And that's a really helpful thing too, because we've basically
linked suppressions to detections.
And again, when you see a little bit,
and when we go to the next slide,
everything's in an IDE and everything is just managed.
But what's nice about this approach so far is that we're
literally in the GUI.
And when we're done
with our tagging, basically, what we look to do
is we look to actually export the rule.
So we go to the top right.
In a second,
that's suppressions.
So we'll go to the top right, we'll look to export it, that
grabs us JSON. And the big important
part here is we're actually, you're
gonna not save the rule.
We're gonna cancel.
OK. So now, we, we've got the rule in JSON.
Let's look at how we're actually gonna go about deploying it.
So now we're, we're in our IDE.
Uh, you can see there's a folder called cloud trail.
Uh, in a second, I'm gonna basically drag the rule
in. I've named it a little nicer because
the name was a little not great.
Um, so there we go, we got our rule.
We're gonna open it up.
Oh, look at that JSON, very nice. It's
got all the configurations that I just set up in the GUI.
I don't have to worry about it at all. It's all there.
So now what I want to look to do is actually look to
deploy this rule
through the RCICD process.
So we're gonna do Python, manage PY,
we're going to do a validate. So this is where our validation
comes into effect, right? Where we're looking
to see, you know, if there's any issues. A note
right off the bat, we have an error.
It's saying that we don't have a CICD tag.
So right away, I'm going to make a CICD tag. Now,
what is a CIC tag?
This is basically a tag that we use to link
our, our rules that are in our Gup repo,
or disk, basically to what's in Data Dog. We
have to have some state, right? So this tag
is the one that helps us control that.
Next, we're gonna look, we got, we got our ID.
Let's go straight and let's look to deploy it.
So we're looking to deploy detections. So now you can see
it's reading local disk,
looking at the JSON.
Great, it's looking good. Oh, great, it's creating
a rule. So now,
should have created a rule.
Let's swap back to the GUI,
uh, in a second. Let's do a quick refresh. So
right now we can see there's nothing there.
So let's do a refresh.
And we should see the new rule in a
second. And there it is.
Wow, very cool.
So, let's look at the tags. It's interesting. So
we got the CICD tag, we see a CICD
hashtag, that's interesting.
And then we see the environment, we see a managed stack ops.
Managed stuck ops tag is very important. We'll talk about this in
a bit. But the CICD hash is also
important. This is how we're able to actually tell when
we update rules, which we're gonna see in a second.
So now that we've created a rule, let's talk about updating,
right? Let's just do a really simple example of updating.
Let's just add updated to the rule name.
But what's going to happen here when we do this, right?
That CICD hash, that tag that we added,
the logic is quite simple if you think about it. We're
just going to compare what's on the local versus what's in Dataog.
If there's a new CICD hash, right? Or
there's a difference in hashes, then obviously you have a different
rule. So then you're going to update it.
It's not pretty straightforward. And that's
sort of how we wanted to design this and make it as easy as
possible.
So we're going to do a validation.
Looks like it's good.
Let's go straight and deploy it.
So now we're looking to deploy.
It's taken a second to read,
and then now, note, right over there,
says updating.
Cool. So now let's go and make sure in the gooey that
it actually reflects this.
So there we go, we see it's there. Let's
do a quick refresh.
And there we can you see the title right over there
it says updated.
Nice. It's exactly what we want.
So now we've been able to create a rule,
update a rule,
but what about deleting?
Now we don't want the rule. Let's say it's a bad rule for some reason. How
do we go about that? Well, this is a really simple
one. If we wanna delete it, let's
just delete the file.
So what we're gonna do is go over here in our
ID and delete it.
Now, one thing I want to clarify, right, if I'm doing all this
in the IDE,
right? Normally, this is done, a
lot of the commands that are happening here are done through CICD
you know what I mean, what I mean by that is it's done through GitOps,
Jenkins. I'm just doing it through in CLI
right now because it's a bit faster and easier to show.
So anyway, we're deleting the file.
We can see that it got deleted.
Let's now go back and let's see
what this looks like.
Yeah, the rule's there. Let's refresh.
Quick refresh,
and the rule is gone.
Awesome. So now we're sort of seeing
again, or how we create rules, how
we update rules, and how we delete it.
So let's talk a little bit more about
how we actually try and enforce this.
So what, what do I mean by this?
So,
cause the fact of the matter is, if you notice, the
GUI, someone by mistake could
press save.
Mistakes happen.
There's also situations where out of the box rules
turn on and they're auto enabled.
If that happens, what happens to our CICD state? Now
we're gonna have rules that are enabled that
we don't actually like
want, right? Like, we're, we're not ready
to turn them on, or they're just mistakes.
So we built a very simple automation, uh, which
basically goes and pulls all the rules that are enabled
in DataDog.
It then checks those tags,
and it looks for that managed secops tag that I
talked about.
That tag is added if a rule
gets deployed through our CICD process.
If it finds a rule that is enabled
that does not have that tag,
then it basically notifies us through Slack
and it auto turns that rule off.
So this is a good way for us to make sure that our state
is, you know, always working. It's always
exactly what we want and what we expect.
However, now.
Let's say we have a security incident.
Are you telling me that during a security incident, we're
gonna have to go through that whole CICD process to make a detection?
Uh, I don't know how I feel about that, right? That
doesn't sound that great, doesn't sound fun.
Realistically, honestly, it wasn't that bad, but like
when you're in a security incident, you want to be able to do things fast,
right, and quick.
So how can we deal with this
situation? Well,
let's, we're gonna sort of hack the system.
What you're gonna do, right, in a break glass situation,
security, and you really need to make a rule and you don't want
to go through the CICD process,
you're gonna make the rule just like we saw initially
in the GUI. However, you're gonna manually add
the tag and manage suck-offs.
This way, the automation that we built will
not turn it off.
And obviously, you know, we know this is a hack and
there's a little bit of like, you know, trust,
right, in the analysts to not abuse this.
And that's something that we're OK with, right? We're building
this for us, we trust
ourselves, right? And to know to not abuse this.
And when the incident's done, we're just gonna go,
go to the rule, export the JSON,
do the things we did the IDE and then boom,
and we should be good.
So, now that we talked a little bit about this, like
rules, let's talk a little bit about out of the box rules and
how we sort of handle these outright.
So, out of the box rules are great.
And I really do think that's important. And I want to clarify
this a little bit more before I talk about this flow chart.
Um,
When, when we look at rules, right,
we want to make sure that
they work for our environment. And what I mean by that is if I
turn off turn on an out of box rule,
I don't know if it's going to be loud or not.
So it has to go through a process,
right? And this is what sort of what this process looks
like. What, basically,
what we'll do is we'll grab, grab
our rules.
And then we'll basically
test them. We'll grab the queries, we'll, uh,
we'll do that.
Something in the future we're actually looking to do is actually use
a historical engine Data Dog has and build an automation
that basically will go and grab all the out of the box
rules that we care about that are disabled and
run a query and check the last 90 days
and see the hits. And then based off that, we already
know with confidence certain rules. Oh, this is hitting
0 in 90 days. It's an interesting rule. We
can probably just turn this on right away,
right? So that's part of that evaluation rule.
And then from there, it's about, it's either enabled or disabled.
One other thing I forgot to mention a little bit earlier,
but in the previous automation that we had,
where we were actually going and,
you know, disabling rules, when we disable
a rule,
we actually send that rule information
to a spreadsheet.
And that spreadsheet keeps track of all the rules we've disabled.
Why? Well, we have monthly syncs
where we basically go through those rules and
discuss as a team, hey, is this rule important?
Oh, it is. Oh, this rule of query makes a lot
of sense.
Let's just look to turn this on. Oh, this
rule makes a lot of sense. They've already done the hard work for that query
logic. We just need to tune it a little bit and add a few
fields to make it work for us. Let's do that.
OK, so,
hopefully that makes sense. Let's, uh, go a little bit
more into it, right? So, in summary,
the challenge of out of the box rules, right? Alert
fatigue, normalization, mismatches,
coverage gaps,
maintenance and life cycle.
But, right,
like I said, they have a lot of value, and I don't want to diminish
that. A lot of the out of the box rules
that we've, a lot of the rules we actually have in DataDog
are out of the box rules that we've taken and just straight up enabled,
or we've added some slight addition stuff.
So the biggest thing is you need to pair it with
an activation plan.
OK, so now we've talked about detection
as code,
talked about a lot about logs.
Let's talk about my 3rd probably
favorite topic or challenge,
which is behavioral detections.
And I'll be honest, like detections and building
detections themselves probably could be its own
big talk, right? But I
wanted to do a bunch of small little things because it makes it more
fun and hopefully you're learning a bit.
So behavioral detections, you know, they're
good, but they're noisy,
right? Uh, let's talk a little bit about
this a little bit more.
So here's a fun picture, right? It's
a behavioral analyst, you're observing behavior,
but is it true or is it not?
So let's look at an example of OCTA,
right? If you're familiar with Octa logs, OCTA
actually has inbuilt behavior logic.
So it literally will tell you, you know, if someone's
doing stuff, is that person in a new city,
new country,
new device, new geolocation, IP
state, you know, velocity, and then it gives you a risk
level, oh, a risk level. We, we love severity,
right? And then it tells you, you know, what's going on.
So, we, you know, want to test this out.
Uh, we made it around basically stuff that our
risk levels around higher critical.
And we made a
rule off this.
And this rule basically says that
in 1 week, we will get 22 detections
for this. That basically
equivalents to 3 alerts a day.
And realistically, honestly, if it just happened like 1
day, it probably wouldn't be that bad. But as it keeps,
if you, the next day starts, you're like, oh, the alerts
are happening again. Oh, the next day happens, the alerts
happening again, you're gonna get start to get really annoyed,
right, by the same alerts that just keep popping up and popping
up, popping up.
So this is sort of the problem, right?
The, the issue though, and it sort of leads into
the next one source I want to talk about,
which is guard duty.
So, guard duty
can be really noisy.
But I'll say a big, big thought.
If you, let's say I have his first example right over there, unusual
IM policy creation, 72 hits, right?
If one of those is a true positive, and
that is an incident,
you need to know about that,
right? You can't ignore that. But are they, are
you going to tell like analysts like me to like
triage 72 alerts?
Probably not, right? That, that's like we
need to find some way of dealing
with this so that we can still actually get
that signal but find a way to fine tune.
And obviously, you could do fine tune like you, you could
do a lot of like things where you grab the detection,
you know, you maybe change severity and some stuff like
that, um, but we came up
with a solution that I think is
sort of interesting, um, and that's what we're gonna get into
right now. So,
next thing, we're gonna talk about observing behavior,
notes the third hand on the notebook
right there.
So, let's look at our signal
explorer.
So, in exactly
Uh,
one day we have
499 signals.
That's weird. I just told you that we don't
want to have a lot of signals. Why do we have
499 signals in one day? That's
crazy. But if you actually look a little bit
more at the color of those little bars, you'll
see a lot of that is gray,
right? Like a lot is gray.
Um, so what's actually happening here
is we evaluate our behavioral detections
that we see that might be noisy,
and the ones we think that are high
fidelity or valuable or we can fine tune,
we'll, we'll keep them.
But there are certain ones that are really noisy,
but we still want to keep that for some type
of correlation. So we'll turn those rules
to info alerts.
So let's sort of see what's going to happen here with when we turn
those into info, info alerts.
So, before I get into this, I sort
of want to talk about something a little important
about alerts and detection.
Generally, any alert has a
few fields, right? They have
IP address, they have host name,
they have username,
they could have a user email, they could have an AWS principal,
right? And those are really, that's
really important because you can use those fields to
correlate across other log sources or other
alerts,
emphasis on other alerts.
So let's, now let's like sort of look at the diagram on the
right. Uh, let's say we get an alert,
uh, from Data Dog. It's like a medium,
which is, you know, uh, medium alert,
cool, cool. It's an octo potential brute force
and to be honest, like, that's also couldn't be
a noisy alert, right? Like people forget their
passwords, right? And they
go, go in a lot, then all of a sudden they, you know, they
remember. So let's say we grab that alert.
It goes, then, you know, alert triggers, it
goes to our store tool.
We then say, OK, that alert had a username.
So user.name, let's say and pitch iconie.
We're gonna instantly do an API call to that
signal explorer that you just saw, like a slide
ago. And we're literally gonna let the query
that we're gonna hit is basically user.name
and pitch iconie at Riot Games. Are there any hits
for that? If there are,
OK,
maybe we look to change this to a high severity.
Right? if there aren't, maybe we
look to keep it as medium or auto close, and
we can sort of make that decision.
So this is sort of how we're actually using behavior
detections or anomaly detections that
are noisy,
but we're still able to cross correlate it
and get value out of them.
So let's sort of like take this and like up at one
more level. So,
let's put it all together.
So, now,
same, same exact detection, right?
Uh, octa potential brute force.
However, now we're gonna look at multiple different type of fields
we can correlate.
Or let's look at, look at user agent, let's look at IP
address, let's look at user name,
right? And then we're gonna take those and cross correlate
that with other alerts,
with other threat intel,
with check authentication,
and then combine that logic, and then from there, we can decide if we
want to alert, not alert, change severity.
Cool, this is great.
However, there's one thing I haven't talked about, and I feel like I
have to talk about it because everyone's talking about it.
And the thing is AI,
right? AAI is a thing, I think we're all aware of that.
And the answer is a lot of this flow chart
that I'm showing you right now, honestly, could be done by
AI. Like that whole correlation
with the user agent IP user hitting check
alerts, uh, check threat intel, check authentication.
AI can do all that for you, very simple AI agent.
To combine logic,
you might want to like AI output what you
want, and then you make the decision on, you know, what,
what you choose to do.
Um,
but what I really want to clarify that's really important, and I want
you to make sure you understand is
you still have to tell the AI what to do.
You have to still know that, hey, we, we
have to have this idea that AI checking other alerts
and looking at these fields.
You need to tell the AI to look, go to virus to. You
need to tell like the AI to check authentication to be specific
about that. So, you still have to have those
fundamentals, right?
And then from there, you can do some cool stuff with it.
Awesome. Well, that, uh, I
hope you enjoyed, uh, 3 different things I talked
about. I'm gonna pass it back to Andrew.
Thanks.
A super cool implementation of
what the world can be like when everything has
excellent API support.
So let's talk about the next phase of detection
engineering because after all this is reinvent and we kinda
wanna be a little bit future forward
and we wanna look at how technology
is evolving to help
make these kind of jobs easier.
So the first big
kind of revolution in the detection
engineering industry is the OCSF
framework. I don't know if anybody has heard of OCSF
before today,
but it is the best effort I've seen
in my career to normalize logs
prior to ingest.
So with companies like DataDog and AWS
leading the charge, this has gained a ton
of traction
across the industry.
The biggest benefit of OCSF
is because logs are coming in in
a standard format with standard attributes
all of a sudden the opportunities
for uh low computationally
intensive operations to correlate
events
become much broader. So like imagine for example
that you had to write an account takeover
rule. In the old world
we would write that account takeover rule for every
platform
that we were ingesting logs from.
With OCSF
we can write a single account takeover
rule that covers every platform that
ships logs with OCSF.
Nathan mentioned as well
that Riot uses uh the
open source log router Vector.
Well, Vector has a a cousin
in the Data Dog product and that's called observability
pipelines, and that's a part of Dataog
that can do everything that Vector does and
some more on top of that.
Uh, this week at Amazon Reinvent
we launched,
uh, the OCSF processor
for observability pipelines, so
that's generally available today, and you can use it
to take logs and transform them
to OCSF,
which is a supported, uh, storage format
in the cloudsI platform today.
So don't miss checking out observability pipelines
and uh obviously if you want a DIY
uh vector is an option too,
uh, open source log router agent,
um, that can also do transformations.
So The next
cool thing on top of that is the
explosion of detection methods,
right? So if, if you look at this
screen, um, uh, up here,
Data Dog supports a ton of different detection
methods
including signal correlations, anomaly
windows, and some of those behavior,
uh, based detections that we talked about like
impossible travel or as I like to call it,
you flew faster than Superman.
You may have also seen our announcement this week that
uh Bits AI SRE
is generally available. Well, Bits AI
also has a partner, and
that is Bits AI security analyst.
Um, it's designed to automate and accelerate
the work of human security analysts,
so it primarily focus on, focuses on
managing and investigating alerts in the cloud
SIM. You can integrate it with automation
and orchestration, so as mentioned,
you could pair that with, uh, something like
Data Dog App Builder to, to carry
out operations like doing a deeper
investigation or a session invalidation,
and it works in tandem with other agents in the
Bits AI family.
So you can check that out uh in preview there
at the link on screen.
So to wrap here, uh, the key takeaways
are that detection is code is
absolutely essential if you're building detections
today, especially for platforms like the
AWS cloud.
Your data pipeline
is absolutely everything, so like so
many things today, data quality,
data quality,
data quality.
That's gonna just like really drive down your your
false positives and increase the precision
in your detections
and then follow process
process process if you took nothing away from the section on how riots
implemented this, it's that they have a very strong
process that acknowledges
some exceptions but large.
It's driving people down that paved
road for deploying detections
and then embrace open standards as well so
you know let's keep the momentum going with OCSF
if you're working with a vendor or partner that doesn't
yet support OCSF
that's a great thing to ask for or a
first issue to file on an open source
project. So
we started the session by saying the goal of
detection engineers is to write
perfectly accurate detections.
With all this,
it is mostly achievable.
So if you uh if you have a cell phone and you wanna
take a picture of a single slide from the presentation,
this is the single slide
to take a picture of because it links out to a
micro site with literally every single
link to everything that you saw in the presentation
as well as ways to reach both of us
after the session.
And uh before we take questions though,
I do wanna mention I think one of the most
challenging things when you're just
getting started as a company is
believing the tools like this can be
accessible to you at your earliest
stage and so I do wanna mention a new
program. From DataDog called DataDog
for Startups, uh, which gives
DataDog Pro or up to $100,000
in credits, uh, during the first year.
So if you're in that
Series A or early startup
stage, definitely check out the
DDFS or Data Dog for Startups program.
And then if you're interested in our other reinvent launches
or you wanna check out uh the deep dives on
things like the OCSF processor
that's available at this link as well.
And with that we will go ahead and take
uh any questions from the room, but I
do wanna thank you for being here
with us today and I wanna thank our uh great
customer speaker Nathan from Riot for
giving an excellent demo.